[Musique]
cette affiche noël mamère flamand
rappelle plutôt des bons ou des mauvais
souvenirs cette affiche me rappelle de
bons souvenirs parce que c'est une
chance pour un homme politique que
j'étais devenu après ma vie les
journalistes de pouvoir
présenter son le projet de société
auquel on est attaché devant l'ensemble
des pays c'est moi je considérais ça
comme un un cadeau qui m'a été fait par
mon parti politique qui s'appelait les
verts à l'époque et puis je trouve que
le slogan que nous avions trouvé c'était
en 2002 est les pieds sur terre mais les
pieds sur terre c'est exactement ce que
défend par exemple philosophe très à la
mode est très très inspirante pour les
écologistes qui s'appelle bruno latour
qui nous explique que nous devons vivre
comme des terrestre et non pas comme des
terrien c'est à dire tenir compte de ce
qu'il appelle notre entourage et pas
seulement les humains mais aussi tous
les non humains tout ce qui fait que
nous sommes que des vivants parmi
d'autres vivent avec le recul je t'ai
quand même pas génial sur cette photo
n'ont pas bon puisque qui bouffe
habituellement on voit uniquement les
gens en bus combat que leurs visages où
on voit là debout les mains dans les
poches mais un président normalement
cesser les mains dans le cambouis c'est
pas les mains dans les poches oui
m'enfin
de temps en temps se met les mains dans
les poches pour se reposer du cambouis
on va peut-être rappeler puisque tu as
dix à vingt ans les grandes lignes de
cette campagne est ce que tout le monde
les a en tête 2002 donc les événements
de la campagne c'est jean marie le pen
au second tour il malheureux jacques
chirac élu avec 80 2% des voix aux
élections et puis jospin éliminé au
premier tour parce que les voix de la
gauche se sont dispersés sur plusieurs
candidats vous l'image marquante que
vous gardez de cette campagne c'est quoi
les badges marquante c'est effectivement
ce tremblement de terre c'est-à-dire le
pen le deuxième tour l'extrême droite au
deuxième tour je voudrais d'ailleurs
profité de cette occasion pour remettre
les choses à leur place il est de bon
ton aujourd'hui de dire que si lionel
jospin a perdu c'est la faute de noël
mamère a je pense qu' il faudrait
peut-être poser la question à christiane
taubira qui appartenaient au parti des
radicaux de gauche et il faut se poser
la question à jean pierre chevènement
qui avait appartenu au même gouvernement
et expliquer et expliquer encore que
depuis 1974 date de la première élection
à laquelle a participé à un écologiste
rené dumont il y a toujours eu un
candidat écologiste à une élection
présidentielle non ce qui m'a beaucoup
frappé ce que je retiens le plus c'est
le soir de l'élection
j'ai dit j'avais été agressé par des
jeunes intégristes pendant la campagne
et j'étais protégé par des policiers du
gign qui sont venus me chercher à la
porte de mon appartement pour la soirée
électorale je ne savais pas en partant
que je ferais 5% était tout près m'avait
dit jean luc bennahmias le directeur de
campagne et c'était dans le en allant de
république jusqu'au lieu de la de la
soirée électorale qu un journaliste qui
me suivaient sur un scooter a frappé à
la fenêtre de la voiture dans laquelle
je me trouvais et m'a dit le pen au
deuxième tour donc je suis je suis
arrivé
dans ce théâtre avec des militants
écolos qui savait pas encore ce qui se
passait qui
le kke était content qu'ils se
réjouissaient d'avoir franchi la barre
des 5 graffeurs qui se franchit doivent
ils savaient pas encore que j'avais fait
5% mais il savait que j'allais faire un
score qui pouvait être honorable
est bon je me suis réfugié dans une
quête dans une loge avec mes copains
pour rédiger un communiqué le hasard a
fait que j'ai été le premier à la télé à
dire à appeler à voter chirac pour faire
pour barrer la route à le pen et a
appelé à une manifestation à la bastille
est donc une heure et demi à plus tard
je me suis retrouvé quelques copains à
la bastille au milieu d'une foule de
jeunes de 20,2 de 20 ans qui
m'applaudissent est parce qu ils avaient
beaucoup avaient voté pour moi se trouve
d'ailleurs que 8 et le le candidat des
jeunes j'avais fait le meilleur score de
tous les candidats chez les 18 24 ans
mais que en même temps j'avais il y
avait 7 e est ce ce choc de le pen au 2è
tour donc j'ai vécu un moment très
paradoxale dont je me souviendrai toute
ma vie en effet alors descendre dans
l'arène politique puisque c'est vraiment
le grand moment de la vie politique
française moi je me disais une campagne
électorale c'est un mélange une
compétition acharnée entre les candidats
mais aussi un spectacle qui déchaîne les
passions et une image m'est venu c'était
celle-là pas si ça vous parle mais dur
ouais mais la course de chars août les
concurrents se disputer ou la foule elle
même les encourage est-ce que ça
ressemble parfois à soros
disons c'est une image oui mais juge je
ne considère pas la politique à la
compétition politique comme une course
de chars
quand on est dans une élection
présidentielle puis c était cette
élection dont vous parlez le principe
c'est de faire passer c'est de faire
comprendre le projet que l'on veut pour
le pays et d'essayer de faire partager
par le plus grand nombre donc sais c'est
pas de la séduction parce que la
politique c'est le contraire de la
séduction c'est l'art de la conviction
donc quels sont les outils pédagogiques
et politiques que l'on trouve pour
convaincre les pots pour convaincre les
français alors le ja ben-hur avec ses
chevaux blancs il faut pas se prendre
pour ben-hur parce que c'est qu'ils
prétendent lave plus blanc général nous
à fukushima il faut pas non plus être le
cygne noir comme les chevaux noirs
du concurrent déloyal de ben-hur faut
tracer sa route voilà et il faut dire il
faut être convaincu que le projet que
l'on défend il peut être partagée par le
plus grand nombre et il peut améliorer
la vie des gens puisque après tout la
politique elle est là pour essayer de
faire en sorte que d'abord que l'on vit
ensemble que l'on partage destin commun
et que l'on améliore la vie des gens et
surtout de ses clients ce qui souffrent
le plus des inégalités ça dit ça se fait
sous les yeux du public on a souvent
l'impression qu'il faut avoir un nom un
talent de comédien pour faire de la
politique et en penchant son mode vie
j'ai vu que vous aviez dans votre
jeunesse c'était dans un cabaret ou même
daniel balavoine a démarré ou était à
côté de vous alors c'est pas daniels et
son frère bernard met donc vous avez
envie d'être chanteur un moment mais
j'étais jeune mais à l'époque j'étais
jeune journaliste en même temps et chadi
les étudiants à l'université à bordeaux
oui j'étais ce qu'on appelle auteur
compositeur interprète et donc je
chanter mes chansons voilà mais c'était
j'adore l'avait pas envie que
nous de la fiche j'ai rêvé j'ai révélé
le chanteur ça n'a pas duré très
longtemps parce que j'étais beaucoup
plus attiré par mon métier des
journalistes mais je suis revenue sur
les planches bien plus tard entre 2017
et 2018 avec un compteur qui s'appelle
nicolas bonneau et avec lequel m on a
fait une vingtaine de représentations
qui s'appelait une vie politique pendant
les meetings le fait de monter sur scène
le trac la ferveur des applaudissements
vous aimiez ça bien sûr bien sûr c'est
une savez vous connaissez ça puisque
vous faites de la télévision alors moi
je faisais des jeux présentés les
journaux j'ai présenté c'est la vie qui
était une émission quotidienne tous les
soirs puis ensuite les journaux de 13
heures c'est de l'adrénaline alors le
trésor en plus à l'époque il faisait 50
minutes donc c'est 50 minutes
d'adrénaline que les jours donc il ya un
peu de trac avant moi j'avais du pont
parce que quand le rouge s'allume et je
me sentais très bien
mais c'est de l'adrénaline la politique
c'est aussi aussi de l'adrénaline c'est
une drogue dure donc on est c'est un
mélange de séduction de conviction et
puis de gratification face face au
public ce pour ça que faire de la
politique uniquement à travers un écran
de télévision des chromosomes ça peut
pas fonctionner parce qu'il faut qu'il y
ait un lien mais je me souviens quand je
faisais des réunions publiques où il y
avait beaucoup de monde
et que je voyais quelqu'un qui dit non
je pensais qu'il doutait de ce que je
racontais mon objectif c'était de faire
qu'à la fin ils applaudissent et ils
soient convaincus je vais montrer une
petite photo elle est anecdotique j'ai
été surpris en europe en pesant sur
cette campagne sur le nombre de
commentaires qu'elle a suscitée tu vois
je vais déposer génial ça c'est pour à
la une de gala loana est hélas par
l'époque vous aviez tant votre moustache
en versé par mois qu'il avait un seul
photographe qui avait eu cette idée mais
comme je comme j'ai une certaine
distance par rapport à ce que je fais en
tout cas j'espère que je la garderais
jusqu'au bout coup c'est mon épouse
d'ailleurs qui est à côté de moi que
d'ailleurs cette photo elle et elle a
été faite un peu à moitié à l'insu de
mon plein gré on va dire j'étais
d'accord pour la moustache verte parce
que je suis d'accord pour faire des
tricks dans ce genre ce qui ne plaît pas
beaucoup au milieu politique qui est un
peu coincé et jeudi au photographe est
ce que tu pourrais faire une photo avec
fonction quand gardera pour nous nous y
ait pas de problème et puis quelques
jours plus tard gérer et se retrouver en
couverture de gala avec fauchon l'ancien
modèle vers chez moi je m'en foutais là
je me suis demandée ce débat un calcul
parce qu'on a besoin d'attirer
l'attention des médias et que les médias
aiment ce genre de la côte est où
c'était peut-être un peu en avance par
rapport à ce qui est aujourd'hui devenu
la règle la communication plutôt que la
transformation la société il ya une
autre chose que j'avais oublié c'est que
pendant cette campagne vous avez des
battus face à jean marie le pen vous
senti un devoir l'affronter
bah oui je me semble que c'était
nécessaire oui j'étais candidat à
l'élection présidentielle
le pen l'était aussi quand alain duhamel
m'a proposé ce débat sur rtl j'ai
accepté j'ai accepté je pensais que
c'était mon devoir je dirais même que
j'ai éprouvé un certain plaisir à le
mettre un peu dans les cordes de temps
en temps mais ce qui m'a surpris c'est
que vous aviez presque entretien avec
bernard tapie parce que vous avez été un
moment sur une usine européenne ou c'est
pas vrai qui a raconté ça c'est vous il
raconté dans un journal il veut un peu
sa vie de coach je me disais tiens non
non il m'a pas servi de kochi bas il m'a
donné des éléments parce que lui avait
affronté le pen mais je n'ai pas avec
lui que j'ai préparé ça c'est avec nous
équipe de copains farbiaz coronado
quelques autrui mais je ne regrette pas
je ne renie rien j'ai fait campagne aux
européennes derrière bernard tapie avec
des personnalités qui aujourd'hui sont
considérés comme des icônes de la gauche
christiane taubira qui n'appartenait pas
aux radicaux de gauche à l'époque qui
dirige un parti indépendantiste en
guyane oui c'est vrai mais à bientôt on
a vu à quel point voilà c'était une
sorte de grand tourbillon cette campagne
électorale est-ce qu'on en sort
complètement rincé alors juger de votre
question est intéressante parce que bien
souvent on entend des responsables
politiques qui ont fait une campagne ou
qui souhaitent faire une campagne
présidentielle d'hier c'est la rencontre
d'un homme et d'une femme avec le peuple
ça c'est la phrase de bayrou je ne crois
pas du tout on fait campagne est-ce
qu'on se rincer au sort par où sort plus
fatigué quand on n'y est entré mais faut
savoir que comme le calendrier électoral
a été inversé c'est à dire que la
présidentielle précède les législatives
quand j'étais au parlement avec mes
copains écolos nous avions voté contre
cette disposition de lionel jospin a
voulu étaient périmés qui fait de la
présidentielle un véritable poison oui
ce qui fait que la présidence avant le
sortait de la présidentielle qui a lieu
avant les législatives et donc
automatiquement c'est à dire
mécaniquement vous avez une assemblée
godillots qu'il ne plus le pouvoir de
contrôle et d'initiative alors qu'on est
dans ce régime qui est dit parlementaire
donc qu'est-ce que j'ai fait les faits
la campagne je me suis bien donner dans
cette campagne va mal j'étais pas aussi
lessive et qu'on le dit ce n'est pas une
rencontre c'était un moment fort qu'est
ce que vous faites dit que la campagne
est terminée dès que les feux se sont
éteints bavoux cours vous allez dans
votre circonscription
et vous faites campagne pour les
législatives qui suivent et vous allez
évoluer toujours mairie j'ai déterré la
baraque se parle avec la compétition
sportive mois quand on fait du sport on
sait bien que il arrive après une
compétition qu'on ressasse certaines de
ses erreurs déshydrate j'aurais pas dû
faire ça donc je me demande si vous êtes
fait des reproches après l'ère
précédente et quand je sais je fais
beaucoup des scream quand j'étais jeune
et j'adorais ça choisi du fleuret pas de
l'épée et c'est vrai que quand j'avais
perdu un assaut généreux français aux
erreurs que la défaite n'est pas être en
quart temps 6 n'est pas maître fondu au
bon moment
mais pas une erreur qui aurait fait
basculer
1.2.3 programme bien sûr à serait
l'acquéreur qui dérobe à l'erreur elle
est connue ces bambous irrévocable chez
les écologistes les primaires on connaît
et une primaire organisée entre
rentrer plusieurs mais les deux qui
restait c'était alain lipietz et moi et
je fais 42% au premier tour alain
lipietz fait 26% et le soir des
résultats du premier tour à l'ats me dis
je vais gagner une étude tu m'as bien en
garder ses 42 posture tu es malade et il
gagne de 60 voix je crois le la primaire
donc je m'incline et ne décolle pas dans
les sondages au point que ses amis ceux
qui l'avaient soutenu à commencer par
dominique voynet qui était secrétaire
nationale des verts
on dirait ça peut pas continuer comme ça
et donc à la hcc très dur sata sans
doute été extrêmement dur pour lui il a
dit je suis d'accord pour renoncer mais
je veux qu'il y à un vote et donc c'est
ce vote se faisait par correspondance
pour tous ceux qui étaient éparpillés
dans le pays est l'un de mes amis qui
étaient chargés de surveiller ce vote
m'appelle j'étais aveugle et me dit les
îles et les je trouve que les enveloppes
sont très épaisse tu vas avoir la moitié
du parti contre toi et donc quand j
quand j'ai vu ça je me suis dit je peux
pas faire campagne avec la moitié du
parti contre moi ça va être une
catastrophe et j'ai appelé béatrice
durée de l'excellente journalistes qui
suivaient les verbes qu'il sur nes du
monde et je lui dis voilà je ne serai
pas candidat mais ma décision est
irrévocable donc elle fait l'interview
qui rêvent au cab et oui
j'avais téléphoné à dany avant qu'il
m'avait dit tu fumes années comme
méthanier kodmani de pardon avant de
prendre ma décision tu fais peut-être
une connerie mais ce ton choix roquet et
donc j'appelle l'apel béatrice
elle fait cette interview elle publie
cette interview la une du monde
qui sur le vendredi est donc là je
reviens de bègles en arrivant à paris
j'avais tout une groupe de copains qui
m'attendait à la sortie du train en
disant tu peux pas faire ça à noël donc
j'ai somatisé j'ai dormi pendant je suis
rentré chez moi mon monde portable
explose et
messi trouvait enrhumé tout d'un coup
donc ma femme me dit ben repose toi
pendant pendant deux heures ce que j'ai
fait et le lendemain dominique voynet
elle me dit voilà noël c'est très simple
si tu n'es pas candidat il n'y aura pas
de candidat écolo aux présidentielles
donc entre le choix d'être ridicule avec
irrévocable et d'assumer mes
responsabilités
j'ai assumé mes responsabilités le soir
j'ai été élue avec une très très large
majorité avec un moment très émouvant
certains pleuraient en rester un moment
important humainement important et
politiquement aussi finalement et le
soir j'étais invité du journal de 20
heures 2e et béatrice schönberg à peu
près toutes les 45 secondes me dise la
cab irrévocable à faire perdre
pas un point peut-être eu un poids sait
pas on parle d finalement des bonnes
conditions pour se présenter l'une c'est
d'avoir soutien de votre parti on va
crée pas si évident mais il a deux
autres est ce que disait pompidou donc
pour avoir une chance d'être élu à la
présidence de la république il faut
réunir trois conditions idéales la
première avoir un tag dimension
nationale incontestable la deuxième être
au pouvoir ou l'avoir exercée et puis
enfin en 3 d'avoir le soutien d'un
appareil d'un bon parti donc on va dire
que la première condition c'est d'être
connu et ça nous a bien remplit cette
condition oui bah oui puisque la télé
m'avait fait connaître oui et d'ailleurs
quand j'entre et quand j'ai été candidat
à la mairie de bègles en 1989 pour la
première fois quand je rentrais chez les
gens ils m'avaient dés étaient déjà
rentrés chez eux et par l'intermédiaire
de la télé et c'était le journaliste qui
voyez jaunies non là c'est pas le
journaliste qui vient vous voir c'est le
candidat et donc ils voyaient ils ont
ils ont mis du temps comme les
journalistes d'ailleurs que je tutoyait
très vite comme on le fait dans notre
métier et qui venait m'interroger et
dans certains ses 10e et pour qui je
prends celui-là il est politique
maintenant il est plus des nôtres
fait gagner des imaginales vous a aidé
en tout cas oui sans doute oui oui oui
mais enfin là
et le principe de pompidou il n'avait
pas rencontré emmanuel macron oui ça à
l'époque mais en tout cas la notorité je
me demandais même si au début puisque la
première fois que vous êtes présenté à
une élection et y est suppléant de
cheese ils permirent ans le fils de
françois et je me demandais c'était donc
comme 88 est ce que ce qu' ils voulaient
venu vous chercher pour ça parce que
vous étiez connu et vous étiez alors il
faut que c'est pour tout vous raconter
il était venu me chercher des gérants
1983 pour être sur sa liste aux
élections municipales que les aides en
82 j'ai dit non parce qu'à l'époque
j'étais beaucoup plus intéressés par mon
métier de journaliste
et c'est l'époque où pierre lescure m'a
demandé de de présenter le 13 heures en
remplacement de philippe labro qui était
partie faire son film rive droite rive
gauche donc pour moi c'était c'était
bien plus important que d'être un
conseiller municipal one adjoint à
libourne la ville de mes parents et puis
il est revenu à la charge en 88 pour les
élections législatives j'avais déjà moi
le sentiment d'avoir fait le tour d'un
certain nombre de choses que je voulais
faire à la télé je ne faisais plus de
treize heures faisait une émission
passionnante qui s'appelait résistance
qui était une émission mensuelle de
reportages consacrés à la défense des
droits de l'homme après bernard langlois
et cette proposition il l'a fait au bon
moment et d'ailleurs quand il a appelé
chez moi il tombé sur ma femme qu'il
connaissait bien parce que l aller l est
du sud ouest comme moi d'aller en
vacances et revigore elle le connaissait
bien et finalement c'est elle qui a dit
oui sans même que je me sois à prononcer
et il est venu me chercher parce que je
sais pas peut-être un peu pour ma
notoriété mais aussi parce que libourne
c'est une ville c'est la capitale de
pomerol de saint-émilion de fronsac donc
c'est une ville finalement ya des
inégalités mais c'est une ville riche
civile de grandes grands crus de grand
château cheval blanc et autres mes
parents étaient commerçants ils vendent
et les chaussures une famille
honorablement connus de cinq enfants
qu'à choisir ma mère
les chaussures ma mère voilà et
est donc si vous voulez je pense que
gilbert a compris que
est ce ce mélange de notoriété et puis
d'un garçon venu d'une famille dans les
enfants sont élevés dans les écoles
privées qui vont à la messe c'est ça
pouvait jouer auprès de l'électorat et
puis en fait on s'est très bien entendu
et j'ai pris goût et à la politique oui
et j'ai fait une campagne avec gilbert
qui est un garçon un homme plus que
délicieux très urbain on sébum bien
entendu oui c'était c'était super on lui
dit avant de se présenter faut avoir une
expérience politique et c'était le cas
donc ce que vous êtes élu en votre nom
c'est 89 oui vous êtes élu à la mairie
de bergues et la découvrir la violence
en politique puis tout à fait oui c'est
une élection qu'on pourrait considérer
comme
quand tu essaies bègles et si tu l'aies
une ville de rugby et donc on n'a pas
peur de se frotter un peu quoi l'image
du rugby quand ça castagne un pur dit
c'était viril mais correct ma première
campagne face au parti communiste elle
été viril mais correct écoutez le soir
du premier tour j'étais en deuxième
position
je suis allé à la mairie mais je ne suis
pas entrés dans la mairie puisque je
n'étais que candidat et dans le parc de
la mairie il y avait plusieurs
télévisions qui s'intéressait à cette
élection et je trouve en face de moi en
arrivant
cinquantaine de personnes avec des
gamins de 7 8 ans qui me qui
m'insultaient qui me traitaient de tous
donc je me suis mis tout seul face à eux
et je leur ai montré que je ne céderai
pas que je ne dirai pas que je ne serai
pas intimider par ces par ces insultes
et je me disais
voilà il faut que je reste faut que je
gagne parce qu'on peut pas on peut pas
inculqué comme ça la haine et
l'insultent à des enfants alors et puis
moi donc c'était j'ai gagné s'arrêter il
ya des familles qui sont déchirés ça a
été vraiment cette expérience elle vous
a été utile dans la série des babors de
l'intérieur les premiers conseils
municipaux je les tenais avec des cars
de flics autour de la mairie quand même
hein il faut savoir ce que c'est la
violence en politique
7ème que de la ressentir à 89 vous
l'avez aussi ressentir pendant la
campagne
mille deux contrats vous ouais je le
ressens tu ressenti comme une occasion
quand ces jeunes juifs intégristes mon
mon attaque et ont tapé dans mon vélo
trial et pris des positions contraires à
l'éthique d'ariel sharon est donc un bon
jeu pris des positions je suis pris des
positions contre la politique d'ariel
sharon mais c'est surtout que j'ai pris
position pour qui les deux états et je
me suis auto si biya je reconnais là
j'ai reconnaît l'existence de l'état
d'israël qui est
un état démocratique un état qui doit
absolument vivre évidemment mais je
pense que la question de la colonisation
et doit être combattu c'est là que l'on
confronte à un support antisioniste
contrairement à ce que certains croient
et j'ai été attaqué par des par des
jeunes qui montrent était à monsieur à
un moment donné a dit la pire insulte qg
qui m a le plus blessé de toute ma vie
ne le touchez pas il est antisémite
voilà et je me suis retrouvé sur la mon
petit mon fils qui avait 20 ans à
l'époque quand il partait le matin comme
moi il y avait un une croix gammée qui
était dessiné sur la porte de mon
immeuble
donc ça que j'ai été protégé et ça
c'était la campagne présidentielle 2002
les 2002 oui
en 2004 quand j'ai marié deux hommes
abel où j'ai été protégé aussi parce que
j'avais subi des j'avais reçu des
menaces j'ai reçu quatre mille lettres
d'insulté à un médecin qui à écrire onze
lettres et la 11e il a dessiné un four
crématoire alors c'est une telle épreuve
de se lancer dans une campagne
présidentielle je crois quoi on commence
à le comprendre forcément on se demande
mais d'où tirez-vous votre force salois
de quelque chose de profond est ce que
vous savez vous savez non je n'y ai pas
où c'est la chanson de johnny hallyday
la même musique et et abris qui faisait
l'intérêt de bernard lavilliers mais bon
c'est bernard lévy a indiqué tincu qui
vient de l'intérieur il a raison je pas
si la politique est un cri qui vient de
l'intérieur faut pas non plus exagérer
on n'est pas ça c'est de l'or de la
mythologie
ont fait une campagne c'est des
circonstances qui vous conduisent l'aja
mais j'imagine et lorsque j'ai adhéré au
vert avec mes copains en 97 que je serai
le candidat des vers le cinq ans plus
tard sont des circonstances qui montrent
que vous souvenez du coût de la première
fois où vous ai dit bah oui je ferai un
bon candidat à la présidence et par
boîte qui les disent et dany cohn bendit
a des journées d'été je suis retrouvé le
nom en ardèche 10 mai noël pourrait être
un bon candidat
voilà donc alors aussitôt évidemment
ceux qui voulaient pas que j'ai c'est
fréquent ou surtout gelé bien pris parce
que finalement j'avais envie oui oui je
me suis dit pourquoi pas je me suis dit
pourquoi pas voilà ce qui eux ne dit
plus un vrai chien non mêlant justement
ce qui vous donner envie ce que moi
c'était lille et de tempérament de chef
qui veut à mort j'ai pas le tempérament
d'un chef tout ce que j'ai je ne suis
jamais je me suis jamais intéressé à la
me suis intéressé à la vie de mon parti
bien sûr mais je n'étais pas dans les
batailles d'appareil alors vous dirait
certains vous diront ils s'en occuper
parce qu'il avait des copains de côté
pour lui ce qui est pas faux
mais non j'ai pas l'âme d'un chef mais
voilà oui une campagne j'ai eu cette
chance je vous le dis de faire la
campagne présidentielle c'est les
circonstances qui ont conduit mais je
n'y ai pas pensé tous les matins en me
rasant ces voix sont des circonstances
est ce que cette campagne présidentielle
défendre l'écologie ce que c'est son nom
vous êtes le plus fier dans votre
parcours politique
je suis fier d'avoir porté les idées des
écologistes et le projet des écologistes
il est toujours d'actualité plus que
jamais plus qu'en 2002 mais c'est votre
grand oeuvre politique coup de pot
suscité au gros oeuvre pour l'autre
dirai peut-être le mariage comme bon
vous parlez est là mais je veux vous
dire je pense que la seule trace que je
laisserais c'est le mariage oui c'est
pas pourtant le plus important c'était
c'était important de prendre ce risque
de montrer que d'abord que les électeurs
ne sont pas aussi stupides qu'on le dit
puisque tout le monde me disait si tu si
tu fais ça tu vas être battue j'ai été
réélu au premier tour donc il faut faire
appel à l'intelligence des électeurs et
des citoyens non je sais pas je veux ce
dont je serai fier mais c'est c'est un
sentiment qui est partagée
que ce soit dominique voynet cécile
duflot alain lipietz qui avec qui j'ai
travaillé tous ceux qui m'ont précédé
et tous ces penseurs de ces activistes
qui je pense est à pierre fournier à la
gueule ouverte à tous ceux qui nous ont
précédés je n'étais que le porteur de ce
que nous partagions des projets de
société que nous partagions et si je
fais partie là c'est vrai peut-être plus
que certains de
ceux qui ont permis que les idées des
écologistes infuse la société française
et que maintenant elle
élargit son spectre dans la société oui
je serai très fier moi il me semble que
papa présidentielle il ya un côté
experience in et c'est l'impression que
celui qui commence la campagne mais plus
forcément le même à la fin à ce que vous
avez ressenti ça moi je n'ai pas
ressenti en tout cas
je pense pas que mes copains vous diront
que j'ai changé après la présidentielle
où le fait près la même dimension
observé commenté on n'apprend pas sur
soi-même au cours de cette rue bien sûr
mai 2002 c'est pas les conditions
d'aujourd'hui il y avait encore un peu
de liberté on était pas et pied
espionner en permanence par des
smartphones et et autres on n'était pas
en liberté surveillée vous avez appris
des choses que j'aime et converse vos
gros pousser mes limites d'abord je
pille et une chose qu'il faut apporte
moi je vis sur le regard des autres
depuis 1970 et puis la télé donc le jour
où vous ne vivez plus sur le regard des
autres vous pouvez vous retrouver dans
une situation cataclysmique puisque les
gens ne vous regardez plus donc il faut
se préparer à ça donc moi je pense quand
on apprend beaucoup plus quand on
regarde les autres quand ils nous
regardent nous encore faut-il savoir les
regarder il ya un effet un peu miroir
malgré tout non pas forcément sans se
reflètent des ponts comme on veut si
vous aussi vous veut chercher chez les
autres miroir mon beau miroir comment on
ne me trouves tu ça s'appelle du
narcissisme
je ne fais qu
compléter c'est ce qui a été dit par un
sociologue américain dans les années
soixante dix christopher lasch sur la
culture du narcissisme bien ce le bon
que
ce n'était peut être pas mal ces
candidats un jour candidat toujours crs
que lorsqu'on a été candidat une fois
dans sa vie et la présidente de la
république finalement on
on est suivi par ça toute sa vie que
samedi dans ce tout vous devez non non
mots on me le ressort de temps en temps
vous fait même des émissions 21 ans
après mais
non non je pense que quand je suis sur
mon vélo que je crois c ur en à borj
content qu'ils m'appellent noël est
plutôt que monsieur ait beaucoup
m'appelle monsieur le maire du bourg où
aller on suit ça rime avec ma mère
peut-être est bien souvent un bonjour
monsieur le maire même s'ils sont pas de
bague personnes venues très fier très
que monsieur le président on enfin non
non ça va me le disait quand j'étais
vice-président d'une agglomération ce
qu'on dit président il ya beaucoup de
gens qu'on nomme président confie cette
position et qu'elle le boulot monsieur
le président
vous ne vous représenterait pas à la
présidentielle vous n'avez pas d'organe
pas avoir fait une autre campagne ils
n'auront pas du tout j'ai décidé en 2010
est d'arracher la perf
de
de dire qu'il fallait transmettre qu'il
fallait passer à autre chose donc j'ai
été maire 28 ans député pendant 20 ans
je trouve que on peut pas expliquer avec
mon avec les écologistes qu'il faut le
renouvellement politique et la vitalité
démocratique et s'accrocher indéfiniment
au risque de devenir pathétique dont il
faut partir quand on a encore envie
c'était pas du tout là pas du tout mais
je pense que c'est quand on a encore
envie qu'il faut partir sinon après
c'est trop tard et puis se dire voilà
maintenant mon rôle c'est le transmettre
d'être un passeur et d'aider cette
génération qui aujourd'hui a pris
conscience de l'urgence
à
permettre de poser les bases d'un
changement de modèle merci pour cet
entretien vous avez continué à
transmettre
[Musique]